vim aqui papel só deixa você chama
charlie é um filme que eu escrevi
chamada maré humana e dirigiu e no final
do do filme é o aparelho no fim do seu
cabeleireiro que lava o cabelo dela e eu
me lembro quando vi essa cena minha irmã
foi assistir o filme para cinema ela fez
isso adorei o filme mas nunca mais
trabalho como ator você é muito ruim
aí a partir daquele dia tenho certeza
que é uma coisa que realmente eu não
poder atuar do do outro lado na frente
das câmeras é e pra mim às vezes parece
meio meio forçada meu meio me dá uma
aflição extrema sem ter que falar em
público mas porque eu faço isso também
porque está essa parte do engajamento
quem está procurando assim eu tô aqui
pra trocar experiência e trazer para
vocês a experiência é muito interessante
assim uma experiência que vai mexer com
a proposta final todos entendam que essa
questão do olhar um olhar sobre a
cultura que a gente fábrica então se eu
tô aqui tempo colocando acima do medo
sim uma necessidade de conversar com
vocês
o nome de que tenha dado meu peça
palestras bobamente era mais um pingo na
pedra é que a idéia era fazer alguma
coisa que foi a insistência muito grande
e aí eu acho que passa um pouco por esse
dia é isso viés político que a gente
está conversando aqui com você é agir
diante das da sua vida quando era muito
jovem e 85 mais ou menos eu tentei não
lembro direito teve um concurso público
do brasil e não inscreveu no concurso do
banco do brasil e eu é que ia fazer esse
concurso vai fazer com o treinador e com
o banco naquela época em que era minha
geração tinha quase 20 anos na época em
85 sabe que o brasil está muito quebrar
ea saída de funcionária pública não é
uma saída bastante interessante para a
vida de uma família
mas é que eu não fiz o curso o curso do
banco do brasil de existir mas calhou
que esse concurso ele foi cancelado
quem sabe que teve a corrupção da prova
vazou alguma coisa e foi marcada outra
data para fazer o concurso e uma vez de
estar voltando pra casa está muito
enganado
estava uma confusão na cidade está isso
mas eu quero que é isso aí eu era a
prova do banco do brasil e eu decidi
fazer a prova 2003 fazer a prova e o
pior aconteceu foi aprovado assim a
minha família ficou assim completamente
não fosse não era o brasil ficará no
banco do brasil não tenho nada contra
mas já tinha trabalhado como office boy
em um bonde chamado do norte mas não era
minha perspectiva sempre tem aquele
momento era tentar trabalhar com cinema
assim o que diga se passar naquele
momento é uma coisa completamente
absurda em 1985 cinema em pernambuco era
patética será risível morria de quem
fazia cinema em pernambuco assim que a
gente vive ela né mas acontece esse tipo
de tite a meta existe uma insistência o
tempo inteiro existiu esse pingo ali
batendo na pedra para fazer um monte de
gente que está de volta
já em volta disso também participando
dessa loucura e quando eu pensei o que
eu queria falar aqui nessa palestra
pensando que eu posso trazer de
interessante para as pessoas talvez uma
experiência com relação a essa essa
insistência mas tem que ter alguma coisa
mais e eu fui buscá lá atrás com 11 uma
lembrança além do cinema trajetória no
subdesenvolvimento que um livro paulo
emílio salles gomes e ele fala alguma
coisa sobre o ciclo do recife
e ele tem uma opinião muito clara sobre
parecer um ciclo de cinema que aconteceu
no final dos anos 20 começo dos anos 30
e aconteceu no brasil inteiro que teve
um filho com a técnica da guarda esteve
ao círculo de portalegre o velho ciclo
pernambuco e foi engraçado que ele
produziu bastante assim foi o que mais
produziu oito anos de existência foram
13 filmes feito pra lá em recife neste
ciclo
mas o que é engraçado nesse momento é
que naquele momento não está querendo se
inserir nessa nova na modernidade da
cultura sempre cinema grande modernidade
então todos esses pólos estão tentando é
resgatar um pouco de cinema mas também
depois de oito anos esse foi o meu caso
eu acho que é a força da indústria
cinematográfica naquele momento kalou
que pretendia meu como utopia um sonho
sei lá o quê como querem chamar né
tecnicamente ultrapassado e não temos
condições de pagar
a companhia cinema que está aparecendo
em uma salada ou ver o cinema colorido e
foi meio catapultando a gente pra trás
mas essa experiência ela não se perdeu
assim certa forma essa experiência
terminou sendo um meio que uma 11 uma
pedra também parada no tempo em algum
momento seja retomado né
nesse período entre a década final da
mesma década de 30 até os anos 80 até os
anos 70 foi produzido coisas muito
esporádicas em recife assim o coelho
site um fim contar quase pronto e
inclusive até possamos assistir filme na
casa do cara pegou fogo o filme
desapareceu depois teve alguns longas
local que é um feito em recife mas nada
que tivesse grande repercussão né tá
vendo a repercussão tenha sido alunos
núcleo de super 8 na década de 70 que
era um ambiente de guerrilha cultural
muito forte muito interessante assim é
talvez um produção cultural que
interessa bastante tanto no brasil como
na bahia como rio de janeiro não pessoas
estavam fadados a se nesta nova queriam
na verdade essa qual é o cenário
cultural cenário artístico naquele
momento estava esperando estar falando
de um período de exceção está falando na
época do governo militar não é isso é
uma arma bastante útil assim ela era
muito pouco visto fiz é recorrente
também na cultura brasileira brasileira
vai fazer muito poucas coisas são
produzidas em determinado momento é meu
cego pra isso mas isso também não é
falta de ambição das semifinais que
também é meu prática uma estratégia de
como as coisas devem acontecer né e
alguns curtas metragens foram foram
foram sendo elas somados também ali até
os anos 80 anos 80 quando eu comecei
basicamente trabalha com cinema e me
aproximei e algumas pessoas que
trabalham já que o cinema no caso paulo
caldas e lírio ferreira na época e foi a
partir daí que o mundo dizendo que
estava em volta e começou a se articular
no sentido que a gente quer fazer então
certamente dessa forma aquela memória
que vinha lado ciclo de 20 ela tá viva
se ela não tenha sido uma atitude vão se
na verdade não foi uma coisa e
consequente ela teria conseqüências
assim talvez a tentativa de continuar a
tentar entrar na modernidade na cultura
se na nossa cultura atual ea gente
começou a articular forma de fazer
cinema sempre é teve uma coisa muito
interessante dos anos 90
isso aconteceu um grande boom cultural
no recife isso talvez pela quando a
cultura pop além da música também do
mangue se juntou com cinema e aí tô
falando em 94 ele fez três curtas que
foram bastante importantes naquele
momento mas os primeiros curtas que se
usou essa linguagem mais pop assim se
aproximam muito assim num o o os curtas
eram maracatu maracatus e marcelo gomes
que a música de chico science nação
zumbi
o cachaça de adelina pontual que a
música do mundo livre s a e odete
zagueiro léo que era um filme de lírio
ferreira amstel né ele ele não tá não
usava o recurso do mangue mas já estava
meio todo mundo ali meio naquele nesse
meio campo o que foi interessante nesse
momento é que aí a gente se reuniu e
começou a articular o baile perfumado
assim baile perfumado um filme da
retomada do cinema brasileiro o filme
escreveu o roteiro junto com paulo li e
terminou ganhando um prêmio em um
festival tem não tem uma repercussão
bastante interessante
chegaram vários meses em brasília
festivais internacionais assim quem não
viu essa talvez fosse interessante de se
ver quando assistiu para entender como
eu tô velha ea partir daí começou um
processo de produção no recife não por
conta do baile perfumado mas também pode
ter mantendo essa regatada nesse sentido
de um núcleo bastante excitante de pra
quem gosta de cinema para assistir
cinema assim esse e se esse núcleo hoje
11 95 pra cá basicamente 19 anos estou
95 de produção do bairro 96 em brasília
mas durante esse período assim começou a
articular uma quantidade de produções
muito interessante
as pessoas geralmente elas acham que
esse cinema ele foi articulado por
benesses governamental não foi
articulado por estratégia das pessoas
que trabalhavam com o cinema
o estado entrou muito depois pela
obrigação de ver que está sendo feito
alguma coisa para ele interessava assim
e isso pra gente é uma coisa muito
importante então de certa forma a gente
mais uma vez tinha pegado a lina pedra
alguma coisa que a gente interessada
o que acontece hoje em dia aí eu vou
dizer também que essa estratégia se
repetiu em outros lugares acho que minas
gerais é um local que é muito diferente
em relação a isso há quem tenha teia de
são paulo vai ter um fim do cachorrinho
perdido
plástico você tem um pessoal do
alongamento será então existe um grupo
de pessoas que está realizando
talvez o cinema mais interessante feita
no brasil assim desde o início além do
cinema novo assim a quantidade e
qualidade assim discussão muito
interessante sobre o que você precisa
ver o que está na cultura brasileira que
cara é essa cultura brasileira que ter
sabe mas ele está sofrendo uma coisa
muito grave a gente não tem visibilidade
assim aí eu vou falar um monte de coisa
que foi falado aqui que tem a ver com
essa coisa da ocupação do espaço
aparentemente os agentes não têm donos
tipo o que a gente consome é refugo de
capitalismo de quinta categoria sabe
essa discussão sobre o o o tarifa zero
com relação à a automóvel passa muito
também por interesse de indústrias que
vêm de carro assim e esse refugo desses
casos o veneno este terceiro mundo mas
os chamados emergentes estão segurando
também um pouco da de ganso do conforto
das pessoas que vive uma vida mais
estádio com a energia limpa um monte de
coisas são assim
a agitação que eu tenho todo refundar o
capitalismo jogado de lado mas eu estava
escola e o dinheiro também continua
gerando um certo conforto isso não é
diferente com relação ao cinema e
aconteceu um lado engraçado em 2005 pela
primeira vez a indústria do
entretenimento cinema colocar nesse
sentido embora as outras como os games
ele ultrapassou a a indústria do
automóvel só perde hoje para a indústria
bélica então quando a gente dessa falta
de visibilidade é ficar pensando não é
nessa inocência não é falta de atitude
negócio a forma de negócio negócio
branca falando da indústria muito
potente muito poderosa que fecha a festa
os cinemas para vocês exibir seus filmes
tipo de todas as pessoas gostariam que
ela vem eu não sei se poderia até não
gostar daquelas assistir seria ótimo se
que vai assistindo a gente jogasse pedra
mas que tivesse a possibilidade de ser
assistido de ser visto que a gente faz
muita falta essa discussão com um com
esse público com as pessoas mas a gente
sente que existe uma política muito
perversa por trás disso
e assim o que é o que propõe o tempo
proposto ultimamente talvez seja esse o
fundo na verdade porque eu tô aqui
falando muito mais um convite que é um
conjunto de corrupção do olhasse acho
que esse é o momento da gente dizendo
caolha 218 tóxica
esse olhar para poder se manter um pouco
mas viveu pelo menos reconhecer a
senhora talvez seja muito triste uma
cultura que não se reconhece na imagem
que ela vê e quando falando mais próximo
de lançar qualquer coisa foi literatura
estou falando de artes plásticas estou
falando de teatro falando da arquitetura
entendeu-se da copa que que bem
certamente assim que qual foi o o dado
de decrescimento arquitetônica
construção dos estádios da copa do mundo
trouxeram arquitetonicamente eu juro que
não sou mais mas tem um mínimo dele de
crítica não vi nenhum é muito pobre
muito pobre
tecnologicamente é quem está fazendo a
gente construiu tecnologia para
transmitir os jogos da copa nada assim
ou seja é está virando uma coisa muito
feia está virando meio reserva de
mercado do outro isso é um é uma
composição muito muito triste é quando
você faz parte de uma nação né e também
a proposta um pouco isso é um pacote de
corrupção de olhar e vou eu vou terminar
é é a fala se lembrando eu tive um filme
passou aqui em belo horizonte inclusive
foi a tatuagem e nuno tatuagem tem uma
frase que eu finalize com um super 8
feito por um artista anarquista da época
é um guerrilheiro cultural e que ele
propõe que ali naquela espécie de ficção
científica filosófica ele propõe que a
gente comece uma pintura rupestre de um
novo tempo assim começa uma nova vida e
eu acho que é mais ou menos isso que eu
proponho é assim que a gente aqui é a
parte boa a minha palestra vai acabar
com uma parte do filme árido movie que
talvez ele fique bastante o que eu quis
dizer pra vocês
a gente pode ver
não sei se você entende as coisas estão
aí a gente não consegue ver é que não
consegue ver se conseguem entender essa
pedra mesmo havendo a pedra do cachorro
ta vendo é um cachorro deitado de costas
pra gente
a cabeça do destilado um cachorro
descritivos e tirar a limpo viu né
sempre antes mesmo de existir cachorro
já tinha pedra
agora eu só vi um cachorro muito depois
repare quando falaram olha ali a pedra
do cachorro eu via por de cachorrinho me
disseram que estava deitada
depois disso só vi um cachorro nem sei
como eu consegui ouvir
as coisas estão por aí a gente ouve
sabe por que o preconceito as pessoas só
querem ver o que deixa é preguiça e
preconceito
é por isso que eu gosto e raul seixas
eu não gosto de opinião formada
mas calma pois bem
ali o alê o elefante essa que foi mas eu
não consegui ver nem com a [ __ ]
só se for um elefante que não existe
mais eu dizia o velho que mostrava aí o
dia tinha fumado bem avançando que
admira
aí percebi que era um elefante afundado
a água tá vendo algo no meio dele a
tromba sair ver a orelha do bicho
lucy nação que eu pensava assim
se aquilo sempre teve ali eu nunca
consegui ver quanta coisa não existe
pelo mundo que está embaixo do nariz ea
gente nem
o negócio é o seguinte cabeça aberta
estar alerta
se a gente pisa seu jeito pode
escorregar na imaginação mas é lindo nas
ruas é todo seu
mesmo que você não queira
também não é pra finalizar um ex-agente
da minha parte só dizer que é minha
proposta é essa sim eu acho que é o
momento da gente também saiu um pouco do
lugar e se colocar na posição que é
chamar as pessoas para produzir várias
sempre precisa se confrontarem preciso
reconhecer e eu acho que tipo o
julgamento que estava uma metáfora
cruzeiro fazendo aí mas me interessa
bastante e acho que é isso agradeço a
vocês